what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and miss marvel episode
4 is dropping tonight or tomorrow you
know for normal people but we will be
watching it tonight and i will be doing
my watch party as well that starts at 11
30 pacific time and i'm really excited
to see where miss marvel is going
because i believe and there are some
rumors going around as well stating this
that the inhumans could be introduced in
miss marvel and the x-men possibly set
up as well i think this show is going to
be a lot more important than we realize
now right off the bat i do want to state
that miss marvel is a very important
show on its own without the introduction
of the inhumans or x-men this marvel is
going to lead up to secret invasion and
it's also going to lead up to the
marvels so right away it's already a
very important show and miss marvel is
going to be a very big superhero in the
mcu for years to come but i do believe
that there is more here than we actually
realize and they started to show that in
the last episode where they showed that
the bengal was taken from a cree also
when kamala was training bruno mentioned
that the power wasn't actually coming
from the bengal it was coming from
inside of her and the bengals simply
unlocked the power so the bengal kind of
acted like the terrigan mist and we've
all thought that marvel kind of changed
the backstory for miss marvel kamala
khan not making her an inhuman but what
if she actually still is an inhuman i
think this could still be a possibility
and i think this could be a gateway for
marvel to introduce the inhumans to the
mcu but in a different way that we know
and the reason for this change no
terrigan mist knowing humans on earth
right now and i'll explain this in a bit
could be because of the x-men and
mutants coming to the mcu i think
there's some connections here and i
think that miss marvel is the start so
let's dive into this and of course be
sure to subscribe to the channel so you
don't miss out on any of the latest mcu
news now if you're a super huge marvel
fan like me you are probably thinking
the same thing marvel can only go so
long without introducing the inhumans
and the x-men in the mcu they are
incredibly important characters in
marvel comics and the stories that
happen in marvel comics are incredibly
important as well that revolve around
the inhumans and the x-men and we
already know kevin feige has already
said that the x-men and the mutants are
coming to the mcu he said this back in
2019 at san diego comic-con however we
haven't really gotten any mention of the
inhumans that is until kevin feige said
that he was kind of open for anything if
the story fits and then spoiler alert by
the way for multiverse of madness we saw
black bolt as a part of the illuminati
and of course professor x so marvel
studios can only go so long until they
actually introduce the x-men and the
inhumans in our main timeline because
doctor strange now knows that they exist
but they could be coming sooner than you
think especially the inhumans and i
think and again rumors are going around
that it could happen in miss marvel
right now some rumors are going around
that the universal in humans could
appear in miss marvel and that the royal
family could possibly be on the moon and
if this is true i presume they are at
adelon and this actually makes sense if
you kind of think about it in terms of
introducing the inhumans and x-men now
right away since the promotion for miss
marvel started and we found out that her
powers are kind of changed we assumed
that she wasn't going to be an inhuman
and nobody at marvel studios has come
out and said oh yeah she's an inhuman
that could be a big spoiler so they're
not just gonna come out and say that if
that's the case so keep in mind just
because they haven't actually said she's
an inhuman doesn't mean that she's not
so we assumed they changed her story but
what if they actually didn't sure they
changed some of it but what if that
inhuman part is still the same now keep
in mind and if you don't know this it's
important to know the inhumans were
created by the cree the cree did genetic
experiments on humans and then of course
with the newer inhumans the terrigan
mist activates their powers and their
genes in fact in the origin story in the
comics for miss marvel it is the
terrigan mist that activates the powers
inside of kamala that obviously did not
happen but what if they simply switched
that what if instead of the mist it was
actually the bengal bruno did say that
the bengal simply activated the power
that was already inside of her that's
kind of a play on what the mist did it's
very clear that the power is in her
genes it is coming from her now this is
kind of what separates the mutants from
the inhumans the whole activation of the
powers now it's very clear that the cree
are going to be involved in some way
shape or form with miss marvel last
episode it was revealed that kamala's
great grandmother got the bengal from a
cree they also mentioned that there was
supposed to be another bengal pretty
much confirming that these are indeed
the nega bands originally in the comics
given to marvel not captain marvel but
captain marvel by the supreme
intelligence so the cree have been
around for a very very long time on
earth we knew that already so the origin
of them experimenting on humans would
make sense this is how we get the
inhumans and of course in the comics
these experiments would have babies and
those babies would eventually go on to
have the same inhuman genes and their
powers would later on be activated but
what if kamala is the only inhuman on
earth with the exception of her family
but i'm talking about activated inhumans
with powers what if all of them are on
the moon and what if there are a lot
more in other parts of the universe you
see in the comics the creed didn't just
experiment on humans they experimented
on other alien races as well and the
experiments were actually designed to
look different because they were
supposed to look like different species
so they could blend in and infiltrate
other species and groups the cree
created the inhumans to fight the scroll
during the cree scroll war which we are
leading up to with secret invasion and
the marvels and here's the connection to
the x-men and the mcu and why the
inhumans actually being on the moon and
other parts in space is kind of
important it's so people can actually
differentiate between inhumans and
mutants look for us super fans we know
the difference between x-men and in
humans but to the normal viewer they
might not understand the difference too
well so by having the inhumans on the
moon and in other parts of the universe
this kind of makes the inhumans seem
like an alien race and which some of
them actually are but it really helps
differentiate the inhumans from the
x-men which we know are coming so this
seems like it's very intentional if the
inhumans are indeed on the moon at
adalon and secret invasion and the
marvels are supposed to be really really
big projects coming from marvel studios
and keep in mind the mcu did kind of
switch things up a little bit in the
first captain marvel film the skrull are
typically bad in the comics but in the
mcu they're apparently good and the cree
are evidently bad so they reversed it on
us however i am assuming that there are
still bad scroll and there are good cree
but we've already seen some of the
brainwashing and manipulation done to
carol danvers by the crease so we can
actually assume that some other
experiments have gone down with the cree
on humans and other species these would
be the inhumans and if the cree and the
mcu that is not the comics did truly
create them to help in the cree scroll
war it would only make sense that we
would see them in secret invasion and
the marvels this could be why these two
projects coming up are very very
important to the mcu plus kevin feige
did say recently that a lot more is
going to be revealed in the upcoming
months and we are going to be getting
major hints at what the whole big
picture is of phase 4 phase 5 and beyond
so i am sort of expecting miss marvel to
tease this just a little bit especially
since it's going to be going right into
the marvels and i actually think it's a
pretty good idea to make the inhumans
sort of off-planet characters pretty
much just like the cree in the mcu some
of them kind of look normal but some of
them look like aliens again that would
be a big way to differentiate the
mutants from the inhumans so the general
public doesn't get too confused because
let's face it marvel studios does have
to worry about that but let me know your
thoughts and your best theories about
miss marvel and the inhumans in the
comments down below what do you think
we're going to see from miss marvel and
do you think the inhumans will be off
planet so that they don't get confused
with the x-men in the mcu comment down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof